hello everybody new impossible let's
play I put on makeup while playing a
game let's do it all right so I got most
of these stencils I got green powder
foundation that's swirly foundation
that's swirly some polka dot crap I shat
them highbrow stuff polymer eyeliner
eyeshadow blush and lipstick I bought
this because it says are you ready and I
sure AM so let's get to it now I just
need a game that I can play with one
hand the impossible game good enough for
me let's go to it okay so I'm what I'm
gonna do
I'm okay I can't even talk yet but I'm
gonna try to do this with one hand which
is gonna be very hard cuz I got to apply
it directly to my face and then somehow
decide that I'm gonna be able to play
this game so here we go oh yeah that's
good so here we go that's really hard to
concentrate and do this at the same time
well [ __ ] get that oh yeah I'm getting
it in my headphones that's the last
syllable if they truly are because it
took out my glasses and ordinarily I can
see my webcam when I'm playing alright
now I can't do that so I'm not exactly
looking at myself while I do this okay
the foundation is all goopy and done and
I have nothing to wipe my hands with oh
wait yes I do this is what I do on the
Internet
so I'm starting to look beautiful but I
cannot quite there I'm not ready for the
ball or something I need more
foundations what I'm trying to say so I
need to take this tonight have a goddamn
thing I did have a goddamn thing it's
this goddamn thing okay so this is
really gonna smooth out your skin and if
you didn't know markiplier is officially
a makeup Channel now so you got to
smooth it out all the way across your
skin so that gets a nice even layer so
that no one can see your inner flaws I
mean everyone can see how beautiful you
are hopefully this can hide the shadow
in my soul uh-huh uh-huh
really getting it yeah [ __ ] I don't even
think that you're SPO okay nevermind
I'll just dive in I'm not even sure what
I'm supposed to do with this one
what is polka-dotty and I have a brush
I'm just gonna stare at you awkwardly oh
okay it's hard to play and not look at
the same time oh but now I'm gonna click
yeah oh Jesus questo oh my god aha
powder everywhere is to make sure that
the foundation don't go nowhere because
it's scared of my face I don't even know
if this is the right step but it feels
right so if it feels right I'm gonna do
it mm-hmm good nose they're real
hospitals because if you don't well
you're gonna die just like top so I'm
starting to look beautiful but I'm not
quite there yet I need more into my face
so I got the foundation over there and I
got what's next I shadow yeah it seemed
good enough to me
maybe eyeshadows last I'll do it now
uh-huh yeah tell me more about how good
I am at games if you want to stop making
fun of me for a second out there you
might realize that my techniques might
actually be some good advice for you
this wouldn't be an impossible let's boy
if I actually turned out good in this oh
I wonder if Geoffrey will ask me out to
the ball hmm no all right now that you
got your eyeshadow all done next up is
[ __ ] I don't know because it's probably
definitely time to do the lipstick so
let's just get that underway uh-huh
uh-huh
ah uh-huh it's gonna go good I feel it
although it before there we go
mmm oh so pretty
everyone's gonna dunk on the breast
uh-huh uh-huh yeah I know you all are
jealous I got the looks and the brain to
play games like this I'll get the best
ereira was better than [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
even need to look at myself when I do it
so mmm-hmm all right so next up it's a
mascara no this is the tricky part
because you really got to make sure
you're not being distracted by anything
because you could poke it in your eye
and be really fattening pain well let's
do this
all right come on oh it's all goopy you
get kid I needed I needed oh come on get
out of there why are you being such an
ass [ __ ] well I got it out if that was
the impossible part I did it oh yeah oh
yeah [ __ ] I really love the fact that
this is so close to my eyeball you know
my least vital organ on my entire body
next my dung ah well that eyes done this
would be just the buzz if I could see
the game and not worry about this object
is precariously close to my eyeball and
all my other
trip ahead no ow ow ow ow my eye sting
real bad everyone knows that mascara is
the best part of waking up mascara in
your eye doing great okay I think I'm
done with the mascara for now so I'm
just gonna put that and not even bother
trying to put it in there I don't even
know what the hell is I think it's an
eyebrow brush oh [ __ ]
ah the price you pay for beauty is
eternal death over and over again once
again how much do I put on me how much
do I put in me is this actually doing
anything is this supposed to be like
this or am I just am I just being an
idiot and futile e rubbing something
against my face Oh what am i asked well
I'm applying makeup to my eyebrow and so
now I got blush here I gotta add the
blush to my cheeks to make it seem like
I'm always embarrassed about what I'm
doing and everyone knows that I'm never
embarrassed about what I do so here we
go
oh this is gonna be fun oh [ __ ] let's
just all be honest here I'm the sexiest
would you do me I do me a Derek that's
just in flying makeup wall playing a
video game is a bad idea
everyone at home should do it also drink
bleach alright there's one more thing
that I need to do and it's the eyeliner
so I probably should have done that
before I did everything else I mean you
know I'm new to this so here we go
definitely not experienced oh yeah I'm
gonna be so [ __ ] what did I just inject
into my eye hang it so bad you're just a
big baby markiplier get over yourself
oh yeah I'm gonna do that well open
because that's just the ha it's just a
darker thing I can't seem to make any
progress today what's done with me I'm
just the worst well I'm done with all
that crap I get to finish it off alright
so now that you look good enough to be
seen in public you want to make sure it
stays that way for the rest of the day
you don't cry it off or something so I
need to put finishing powder on it so
that it stays in place because
yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yes oh I'm
so pretty look at my oh look at me why
aren't you looking at me why aren't you
looking at me why are you looking at me
I think my stubble really complements
what's going on with the rest of my face
it all ties it together in the most
perfect way if you don't mind me saying
oh you do mind me saying well screw you
I'm beautiful I wanna make sure you get
it in the nose cuz that's the most
important area ah am I supposed to hit
myself very hard with this tell me I'm
pretty
no okay well I think I used everything I
don't have anything here that I could
put more on my face so who wants to go
out with the margon liar where's my
Fedora I think I've broken new ground
and what pretty can really be or what
ugly could be but do you know why I
broken new ground oh my god I look like
a freaking cloud oh wow oh wow you guys
have had to stare at that for the last
five minutes I am so sorry peak so
anyway so if anyone out there wants to
take me out of the day you know where to
find me on the corner of nightmares and
repressed childhoods so thank you all so
much for watching and allowing me to
scar you for life if you enjoyed this
video please click the like button down
below and if you enjoyed it even more
share with a friend thanks for watching
or else I'm gonna be under your bed
tonight you don't want to see this
smiling face ever again do you good bye